you are the founder and CEO of effectiva
which is a big company that was acquired
by another big company Smart Eye and
you're now the deputy CEO of smart eyes
so you're a powerful leader you're
brilliant you're brilliant scientist a
lot of people are inspired by you what
advice would you give especially to
young women but people in general who
dream of becoming powerful leaders like
yourself in a world where perhaps
um
in a world as
perhaps doesn't uh give them a clear
easy path to do so whether we're talking
about Egypt or elsewhere
you know here you kind of describe me
that way
um kind of encapsulates
I think what I think is the biggest
challenge of all which is believing in
yourself right
I have had to like grapple with this
what I call now the Debbie Downer voice
in my head
the kind of basically
is just shattering all the time it's
basically saying oh no no no you can't
do this like you're not going to raise
money you can't start a company like
what business do you have like starting
a company or running a company or
selling a company like you name it it's
always like and
and I think my biggest advice to not
just women but people who have
who are Taking A New Path and you know
they're not sure
to not let yourself and let your
thoughts be the biggest obstacle in your
way
and I've had to like really
work on myself
to not be my own biggest obstacle so you
got that negative voice yeah
um so is that am I the only one I don't
think I'm the only one no I have that
negative voice I'm not exactly sure
if it's a bad thing or a good thing I've
been really
torn about it because it's been a
lifelong companion so it's hard to know
it's kind of um
it drives productivity and progress but
it can hold you back from taking big
leaps
I think you I the best I can say
is probably you have to somehow
be able to control it so turn it off
when it's not useful and turn it on when
it's useful
like I have from almost like a third
person perspective right somebody is
sitting there like yeah like because it
is useful to uh to be critical
like after
um
okay I just gave a talk yesterday
uh at MIT and I was just you know
there's so much love and it was such an
incredible experience so many amazing
people I got a chance to talk to but you
know afterwards when I when I went home
and just took this long walk it was
mostly just negative thoughts about me I
don't like I one basic stuff like you I
don't deserve any of it and second is
like
like why did you that was so dumb you
said this that's so dumb like you should
have prepared that better why did you
say this
but I think it's good to hear that voice
out all right and like sit in that and
ultimately I think you grow from that
now when you're making really big
decisions about funding or starting a
company or taking a leap to go to the UK
or take a leave to go to America to to
work a media lab though yeah there's a
that's uh
you should be able to shut that off then
because
uh you should have like this weird
confidence almost like faith that you
said before that everything's gonna work
out so take the leap of faith take the
leap of faith despite all all the
negativity I mean there's there's some
of that you you actually tweeted a
really nice
uh tweet thread uh it says quote a year
ago a friend recommended I do Daily
Affirmations
and I was skeptical but I was going
through major transitions in my life so
I'd give it a shot and it set me on a
journey of self-acceptance and self-love
so what was that like you may maybe talk
through this idea of affirmations and
how that helped you yeah because really
like I'm just like
move myself as a kind person in general
but I'm kind of mean to myself sometimes
yeah and so
um I've been doing journaling for almost
10 years now
um I used an app called day one and it's
awesome I just journal and I use it as
an opportunity to almost have a
conversation with the Debbie Downer
voice in my it's like a rebuttal right
like Debbie Downer says oh my God like
you you know you won't be able to raise
this round of funny I'm like okay let's
talk about it
it's one Z
it's literally like in so I wouldn't I
don't know that I can shut off the voice
but I can have a conversation with it
and it just it just um and I bring data
to the table right
nice so so that was the journaling part
which I found very helpful but the
affirmation took it to a whole Next
Level and I I just love it I I'm I I'm a
year into doing this and you literally
wake up in the morning and the first
thing you do
I meditate first
um and then and then I write my
affirmations and it's it's the energy I
want to put out in the world that
hopefully will come right back to me so
I will say I always start with my smile
lights up the whole world
and I kid you not like people in the
street will stop me and say oh my God
like we love your smile yeah
[Laughter]
so so my affirmations will change
depending on you know what's happening
this day is it funny I know don't judge
don't judge no that's not what
laughter's not judgment it's just
awesome I mean it uh it's true but
you're saying affirmation somehow hope
kind of uh what is it they do work to
like remind you right of the kind of
person you are and the kind of person
you want to be which
actually maybe in reverse order the kind
of person you want to be and that helps
you become the kind of person you
actually are that
it's just intention ality to like
to like what you're doing right and so
by the way I was laughing because my
affirmations which I also do are the
opposite oh you do oh I don't have a my
smile lights up
hahaha
what maybe I should add that because
like I I have I just I have everything
oh my boy I just it's uh it's much more
stoic like about focused about this
that's kind of okay but the joy the
emotion that you're just in that little
affirmation is beautiful so maybe I
should add that
yeah I have some like focused stuff yeah
but that's usually that's a cool start
it's just after all they're like smiling
you're inspiring playful and joyful and
all that and then it's like okay I kick
butt let's get [ __ ] done right this does
the get [ __ ] done that for me okay cool
so uh like what else is on there
oh what else is on there
um well
I I have I'm als I'm I'm a magnet for
all sorts of things so I'm an amazing
people magnet I attract like awesome
people into my universe uh so that's an
actual affirmation yes that's great yeah
so that that's and then yeah and that
somehow manifests itself into like
working I think I think so
yeah like can you speak to like why it
feels good to do the affirmations
I honestly think it just
grounds the day
and then it allows me to instead of just
like being pulled back and forth like
throughout the day it just grounds me
I'm like okay like this thing happened
it's not exactly what I wanted it to be
but I'm patient or I'm you know I'm
I trust that the universe will do
amazing things for me which is one of my
other consistent affirmations or I'm an
amazing Mom right and so I can grapple
with all the feelings of mom guilt that
I have all the time
um or here's another one I'm a love
magnet and I literally say I will kind
of picture the person that I'd love to
end up with and I write it all down and
hasn't happened yet but it what are you
picturing this is Brad Pitt Brad Pitt
because that's what I picture okay
that's what you picture yeah okay I'm
running holding hands running together
okay
um no more like Fight Club that uh The
Fight Club Brad Pitt where he's like
staying all right people will know okay
anyway I'm sorry I'll get off on that do
you have uh like when you're thinking
about the being a love magnet in that
way are you picturing specific people or
is this almost like um
in the space of like energy right it's
somebody who
um smart and well accomplished and
successful in their life but they're
generous and they're well traveled and
they want to travel the world things
like that like they're Head Over Heels
into me is like I know it sounds super
silly but it's literally what I write
yeah and I believe it'll happen one day
oh you actually right so you don't say
it out loud no I write it I write all my
affirmations
yeah if I'm alone I'll say it out loud
yeah
try that huh it I think it's which
what feels more powerful to you to me
more powerful
saying stuff feels more powerful yeah
yeah writing is
um
writing feels like I'm losing
losing the words like losing the power
of the words maybe because I write slow
do you hand write no I I type it's on
this app it's day one basically and I
just I can look the best thing about it
is I can look back yeah and see like a
year ago what was I affirming right so
it also changes over time it it it
hasn't like changed a lot but it but the
focus kind of changes over time I got it
yeah I see the same exact thing over and
over and over oh you do okay there's a
comfort in the in the sameness of it